if you're already concerned about the
direction of the united states i don't
know that today's program is going to
make you feel that much better we had
two major rallies in the united states
uh this weekend
um each more depraved than the last we
had the march for life anti-abortion
rally which we're going to get to we
also had the anti-vaccine defeat the
mandates rally in washington dc and this
rally was headlined and this makes me
really sad because i know the guy
very nice guy in in private uh not a
dumb guy uh robert f kennedy jr who as
some of you know i i've had dinner with
in a small group and and
is someone that through environmental
lawyers i know is is kind of in my
circle uh robert f kennedy jr headlining
the defeat the mandates rally in
washington dc
and um
saying that vaccine mandates are worse
than the
nazi holocaust i mean this really is
tough to watch
the context of this rally before we get
to the clip is that these this was
supposedly an anti-mandate rally not an
anti-vaxx rally but a lot of the people
there are historically anti-vax robert f
kennedy jr
at one point i tuned in and there was a
woman talking about vaccines causing
autism i mean for all the claims that
they're only against the mandates
it was all
of the typical anti-vac stuff a rock dr
robert malone was there
dr peter mccullough sort of a who's who
of joe rogan guests
and um i'm gonna play this clip for you
and it it's
this is maybe one of the most disgusting
things i've seen and it's particularly
um uh disturbing because this this is a
guy i know who i i had dinner with once
and
he seemed completely
connected to reality so here is uh
robert f kennedy jr listen to this this
clip going viral yesterday take a look
even in hitler germany you could you
could cross the alps into switzerland
you can hide in an attic like anne frank
did
i visited in 1962 east germany with my
father
and met people who had climbed the wall
and escaped so it was possible many died
truly but it was possible today
the mechanisms are being put in place
i will make it so none of us can run and
none of this this is absolutely
unconscionable and disgusting now
it's also historically inaccurate in the
sense that
they they got anne frank and her family
and killed her so she was only eve
even if you concede the completely
disgusting vile trivialization of the
holocaust and you you know you put aside
ten different things
they got anne frank and frank couldn't
hide at the end of the day they got her
and they got her family and they killed
her
but what is the obsession here with
trivializing the trauma of the holocaust
vaccine requirements to get your kid in
school are like when the nazis killed
the jews conducted
disgusting medical experiments on them
imprisoned them in work camps gassed
jews
that's like when a school says for
everybody's safety little joey's got to
get a few vaccines
and there was a very good tweet from the
auschwitz memorial museum account saying
quote exploiting of the tragedy of
people who suffered
were humiliated
tortured and murdered by the
totalitarian regime of nazi germany
including children like anne frank in a
debate about vaccines and limitations
during global pandemic is a sad symptom
of moral and intellectual decay and
understand that bobby kennedy's not even
just exploiting the tragedy of the
holocaust he's saying it wasn't as bad
as what's quote happening to them now
and of course nothing is happening now i
want to play a couple other parts of
this
let me just play it and and then i'll
comment because there's also some other
interpretation not interpretations
there's some other aspects to this hi
within five years we're going to see 415
000 low orbit satellites wait what
bill gates says his 65 000 satellites
alone
will be able to look at every square
inch of the planet 24 hours a day we
already can by the way
they're putting in 5g
to harvest our data and control our
behavior
digital currency that will allow them to
punish us from a distance and cut off
our food supply
so it's like he goes into other
conspiracies
i actually this this is where
bobby kennedy's intelligence actually
comes through
it sounds like he's doing all of the
same
conspiracies that a lot of the
anti-vaxxers do 5g and
you know government control and all
these different things but if you listen
he's actually being really careful
because even when he talks about 5g he's
like they're going to be able to harvest
our data and control our behavior he's
not actually saying the stuff the 5g
people say about
neurological control
he's saying he's sort of saying like 5g
has more bandwidth and thus it'll be
easier to harvest data about our
activities online
and then use that to guide us to buy
certain products or like but my point
here is he seems to know that that part
is total bs and he's like stopping short
and using coded language that sort of
sounds like the conspiracy but really
isn't same thing with cryptocurrency
like they're going to use cryptocurrency
to to
kill our supply chain
that he he's
virtue signaling to the conspiracy
theorists who are buying his book and
making it number one on amazon and
whatever else the book about dr fauci if
you can imagine
but
that when i see that is when i think
this may be to some degree a little bit
of a grift and he may not believe
everything he's saying doesn't make it
any less damaging and we have to condemn
this disgusting stuff many appeals to
violence from the crowd goers if you
looked in the crowd the signs people
were holding there was one that said
shoot those who try to kidnap and
vaccinate your child
and that quotes exodus 21 16 which reads
quote anyone who kidnaps someone is to
be put to death
okay
lots of holocaust trivialization
people with the stars of david some of
them you know some we some call them
jewish stars they were all over the
place we have one on the screen for you
and then a really bizarre moment some of
the musical entertainment um
this there's like a sort of dance thing
that was going on it did look like the
person dancing was having a stroke or a
medical event of some kind like every
aspect of this was insane let me just
play this for you if you're not watching
today if you're just listening just
imagine someone appearing to have a
stroke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
anyway hopefully they did get medical
help for that individual if needed
disgusting rally
and really a sign that things are not
going very well in this country and then
we've got the other rally to talk about
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes